Paul asks we get like five using our
video three of them being from us had a
very new in small channels gained a
following when people don't interact
Paul nice ratio on your viewership
because for Wine Library TV I had a
similar thing and it was my grandma on
mom so I know that world the reason I
was able to build up my channel back in
a day and now as well though I have a
bigger base now and you can argue that
is the quality of the output right I
mean at the end of the day how are you
gonna find traction there's two ways one
you can put out great content that's
what I do too and I don't know if that's
what you do maybe you stink so we need
to talk about that to you the biz dev
show this man right so I've done all my
biz dev my entire career but I'm getting
stretched so thin so Alex D s is going
to come in and start doing this dev so
when I see something from a tweet from
one of you and you want to distribute
this content on your page that used to
go to my inbox and it would disappear or
or the new Wine Library calm and there's
wine content there and I want to get
that distributed cuz you have a food
blog and you'd hit me up on Twitter that
would get passed on but now he can
capture that and bizdev so it's about
biz dev you now don't have anybody
talking about you cuz you're five years
and all those things but you need to biz
dab in reverse I've been lucky enough to
have a twenty year well-executed
successful career so it comes to me I
deserve it it's capitalism you have not
done that yet but you will hopefully I
want you to I want to look back at this
video and be excited that you did when I
didn't have that I had to biz death when
Wine Library with shoppers discount
liquors and nobody gave a crap I walked
around the neighborhood and knocked on
restaurant doors and said can you put
these flyers on your counter for a 20%
off coupon buy the case of wine I
hustled you my friend need to hustle
number one the variable is your creative
no matter how much you hustle and sell
and put up flyers Steve and put out
flyers podcast listeners that was Steve
playing something in the background I
apologize he just doesn't have any
manners uh no matter I was on a big
point to stick no matter how hard I
hustled and and and put out flyers and
and made it happen when people came to
Wine Library if we didn't have a good
selection if we didn't get good prices
if we didn't have good customer service
we lost so the two variables are can you
bizdev can you make it happen are you
willing to hustle
do you realize that we can't be romantic
that we're just gonna put out an awesome
show and it's all going to work out
[ __ ] what needs to happen is you
have to put out an awesome show in it
and then hustle your face off 15 hours a
day to get people to care that's very
different than spamming people that's
very different than going to Twitter be
like watch our show watch our show watch
our show even in a world where you don't
have a huge audience you have a way to
bring value to somebody if you can
figure out how to do that and then
leverage that value for them to give you
what you want which is exposure you will
win it blows my mind how many people
email me every single day saying Gary
can you tweet about my show in a world
where I'm such a hustler and such a biz
dev guy and such a wanter to give to
like people on the rise and none of them
ask what they can do for me or do
something for me like where's that video
where's your video show saying hey we
want to do like five custom Gary Vee
videos in our world will give them to
you you can use them as assets and then
maybe you can give us some love no
because people think about themselves
and how do I get views and what the
whole world is Predacon when predicated
on when you're doing business can I give
that person 51% of the value of the
situation because if I do then they'll
say yes and then I can get 49% of the
value and that's what I do day in and
day out and day in and day out and
that's why I continue to win in a world
where people want 100 percent of the
value you wanted this question answer
because you want the answer and you were
hoping that you could get on this show
and get the exposure right for your
channel and you know what I'm gonna be a
good guy
d-roc link it up there it is can't you
do stuff within the YouTube world there
you go you got some views now bring some
value oh crap wait subscribe
do I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe